[Music]
tj
is in new york city hi tj welcome to the
ramsey show
hi how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
uh so i'm 22 i just graduated in
december of 2021
i got my job during corona i'm out of
student debt
and i want to leave but the job and i'm
still living with my parents but the
thing is
since i just since i just turned debt
free
i have a thousand dollars uh for
emergency fund i don't know if it's okay
to leave or should i wait longer
leave what your parents are the job both
will you have another job lined up uh i
have
offers coming in um and i i have a lot
of interviews all the time it's just
when i do the numbers in my head if i
move out i won't be making as much money
as if i was at home in terms of how much
i can take in because obviously if i
live at home i'd also worry about rent
well anybody that has free rent has more
money no duh
right but at some point that doesn't
work like when you're 50 years old that
don't call me and say you won't live
with mom
because it's free right so you want to
get out on your own and start your adult
life that's a normal process young man
i'm proud of you do that
yes okay um i was just wondering if um
but can you afford it i mean are you
gonna how much you're gonna be making at
the new gig
so right now my average would be around
50 000.
okay and where are you going to be
living doing that
what city i uh i've
been interviewing in places in new york
um
plays in connecticut and plays in boston
so i i know that's another question too
is it okay to move far away
from uh you know like from the pair like
from your parents or
whatever the case may be like you
because i might not know anyone in a new
city
uh well it's certainly not against the
law
um yeah it's a matter emotionally it's a
matter of emotionally and relationally
what you want to do
right kind of a homebody if i'm gone
very long
i i miss my wife and my family and my
kids and my
so i like to get back home i'm not
somebody that likes to be far away
other people i want to be far far away
uh there's nothing
wrong it's just a matter of what how you
want to live what what kind of a life do
you want to create for yourself
but the three areas that you described
are not far from new york city at all
your parents are obviously in new york
city so
um you know but all three areas you
described are very expensive areas to
live in and you're talking about only 60
000
income which is great coming out of
school that's not a bad income but it is
not living in manhattan income
yeah and like i realized that when i
started looking for new jobs that when i
when that happened
i'm going to be making like nothing in
terms of savings
it's just going to all be going to rent
or food or whatever the case may be yeah
you need to lay out a written budget not
in your head
and develop a game plan that the that
you can live
on what you're going to be making in a
certain area
okay and so if i take this job in boston
i can get a
apartment for this i can pay my
utilities
i can buy food and this will be my
income and you need to project all of
that out so that you're not
you know launching yourself into
a problem but you should be able to pull
this off
and yes you should do this